el corazón de badín se acelera cuando el
sonido de la artillería suena cerca va
esquivando el peligro para poder
transportar ayuda humanitaria del ibi
fajar kif dos días de trayecto
recorriendo ucrania de oeste a este
da miedo muchas veces estamos muy
nerviosos sobre todo cuando pasamos por
los checkpoints o cuando estás cerca de
los ataques con artillería o caen los
misiles
da mucho miedo cuando estás en un atasco
y escuchas el sonido de los ataques esto
nos transporta en tiendas de campaña y
medicinas también evacúan a vecinos que
escapan a la desesperada de los
bombardeos continuados del ejército ruso
en kharkiv una de las ciudades más
martirizados por la invasión rusa
hacemos esto porque estamos unidos por
una idea unidos por el dolor
porque yo personalmente no puedo
quedarme sin hacer nada
y no puedo esperar quieto sin hacer nada
viendo lo que está pasando en mi propia
ciudad y entendí que muchos de mis
amigos estaban allí con muchas familias
y que nos interesemos dmitro era
baterista de un grupo antes de sortear
fragmentos de metralla para ayudar a sus
vecinos en su teléfono guarda las
imágenes que se van encontrando en el
camino el humo y la destrucción de
perímetro novio decidió viajar para
ayudar
la primera vez fueron mis amigos los
amigos de mis amigos y después fue mi
familia
no querían irse de casa porque era duro
para ellos con home
la guerra mató a su abuela ya su padre
pero dmitro apenas reflexiona sobre ello
tan sólo piensa en sobrevivir y en
ayudar a los que aún no han muerto lo
mismo hace badín su vida solo eso le
permite en tiempos de guerra
[Música]